[MUSIC]
Hello, and welcome to our conference call,
MBA Admissions Insights,
Getting Ready to Apply.
Thank you for joining us.
My name is Allison Davis.
I'm associate director in
the MBA admissions office.
I'm joined by my colleague Luke Pena,
director of MBA admissions.
Hi everyone.
>> In the next 30 minutes
we'll be talking about
what to keep in mind as you consider
applying to business school.
We'll start by debunking
a few common misconceptions.
Then we'll discuss some questions that
you may find worthwhile to ask yourself
at this stage in the process.
With some tips on how to
go about answering them.
We'll wrap up by answering some of
the questions submitted by you in advance.
So let's get started, Luke,
by debunking a few myths.
First myth, people with my background
don't go to business school.
>> Hm, sure I hear this a lot.
I can debunk this myth.
Look, once upon a time the profiles
of business school students,
I do believe it was very narrow.
But management education has evolved
a lot in the last few decades and
the last few years.
So now you see many business schools
focusing much more broadly on
the idea of developing leadership.
And so this means aspiring managers
are now recognizing good leadership.
This is needed across all industries and
across all companies,
not just along the so
called traditional backgrounds.
In fact those of you who with academic and
professional backgrounds where
leadership training is less common
actually may have the most to gain from
an MBA and the most to contribute.
>> Absolutely, the potential for learning
and for impact with the background that
might not be called traditional
to specially pronounced.
So at Stanford, we don't have a preference
for a certain academic background or
a certain professional profile.
We take the position that diversity
of experience as immensely and
it's integral to your experience.
So that means there's
not one right profile.
There's also not a correct
socioeconomic profile and
I know that's often a great concern, and
many of you might worry about the cost,
and we work to help offset this cost
with need-based financial aid programs.
So, I believe that regardless of your
background, if you're excited to learn and
grow, if you want to help others learn and
grow,
if you're passionate about
leading organizations and
changing the world in meaningful ways,
you should consider a Stanford MBA.
Here's a common myth.
I'm too old to pursue an MBA or
I'm too young to pursue an MBA.
>> [LAUGH] Sure.
Well, let me dispel
with the notion of age.
We don't consider your age
in this process at all.
We think about this as career stage.
And look, people at all different
career stages can benefit from an MBA.
Now, acknowledge the reasons and the
objectives for pursuing an MBA can differ
a lot based on where you were on your
career and that's great and that's fine.
I tend to think it's exciting to be
part of community like Stanford where
there's a range of objectives and
goals but
everybody wants to create meaningful
impact and we sometimes call it an insane
level of greatness and
we acknowledge that everyone defines that
greatness is a different way including
based on where you are in your career.
So I tend to think of the MBA
as an investment, right,
it's an investment in yourself and
in the communities in which you operate.
And there's probably never a wrong
time to invest in your own
learning and development.
>> That's right.
It's never too early in your career
to invest in being a better and
more self aware leader.
On the flip side,
you're never too experienced to
invest in your leadership ability.
So at Stanford, we like having this range
of experience in the class where you can
learn from others who have different
profiles, different levels of experience.
So regardless of the experience level,
if you recognize the value of this
investment, and investing in
your leadership ability, again,
I'd encourage you to
consider the Stanford MBA.
>> Another myth, an MBA would narrow my
professional options, not broaden them.
>> Hm, well, this is a myth that
I think mirrors the first myth.
That we talked about, which was about
a narrow set of pre-MBA backgrounds.
This is the flip side.
This is that there
are narrow post-MBA paths.
So let me dispel this myth.
Remember, we talked about
management education evolving.
It's become largely industry and
company agnostic,
and its focused on developing better and
more impactful leaders.
So at Stanford we focused on things
like general management curriculum.
We talk about innovative thinking,
we focus on personal leadership
development and global understanding.
These are all concepts
that are applicable across
a wide variety of professional paths.
So this means you can apply
this tool kit of skills and
experience, you can apply it to whatever
noble pursuit has meaning for you.
>> When you say that another way
the MBA broadens your options is
through the community?
>> Sure, sure that's a great point.
You have a diverse community of
classmates and alums and faculty, and
these individuals are providing you
exposure to a wide variety of career path.
So, many of these career paths are ones
you may have not encountered before.
So, at Stanford you're given these
opportunities for exploration, and
access to our community that
encourages exploration.
So, my belief is that Stanford MBA
actually positions you for
a much broader set.
Professional options.
It also imparts you with
the transferable skills
that will allow you to change
paths all throughout your career.
>> Okay last myth.
It's best to know what my post MBA goals
are before I go to business school.
>> Mm yeah.
Well this builds on our
discussion at the last myth.
So MBA at a place like Stanford we talked
about how this broadens opportunities for
professional options.
So what this means is that in business
school it is actually a great setting,
maybe even the ideal setting,
to exercise your curiosity,
to explore different career paths.
And it's ideal here, because you can
explore and the downside risk is low.
You can use your time here as a student
to do things like pursue an internship in
a completely different field, or
shadow a practitioner from industry.
Or even just schedule things like coffee
chats or lunch talks to explore and
satisfy this curiosity.
And students who explore
sometimes find their goals change
even as they're exploring, don't they?
>> Absolutely,
you might be surprised to hear that it's
actually 75% of our students here
that switch careers after the MBA,
and this is in large part because of this
exposure to classmates, and alums, and
the faculty and the visiting speakers that
Give you these opportunities to explore.
And so you may even have an idea of goals
coming in, and that may change and evolve
as you interact with all these different
kinds of people in the community.
So I will say if you are somebody
who has very clear end goals,
you are very welcome at Stanford.
But you are equally
welcome if your reason for
pursuing an MBA at
Stanford is to explore and
of course we'll be very interested in
hearing about the ways you do that.
>> Thanks, Luke.
Next let's talk about questions
that you should be asking yourself
as you're getting ready to apply.
In fact answering these questions for
yourself now can probably save you
time later in the application process.
So one thing to ask yourself that's useful
is, is an MBA the right degree for me?
>> Mm-hm, yeah.
Well let me start making an assumption and
this assumption is that if
you're listening right now.
You are interested in growning,
you are interested in improving both
on a professional and a personal level.
So I make that assumption.
So to answer this question
is the MBA right for me,
you have to ask yourself
how do you want to grow?
How do you want to improve and
evolve and change?
And so there are lots of ways to do this.
And I will acknowledge some
of the different paths.
You know, some of you are deciding MBA or
stay in the job?
Graduate degree or stay in the job?
And maybe your current job gives you
opportunities to grow and develop.
Some of you are deciding which kind
of a graduate degree to pursue.
There are graduate degrees, other
professional degrees, I acknowledge that.
Some of you have decided that management
education is right for you, but
there are different formats.
There is part time, there is executive
programs, there's online programs and
certificate programs, and
these all have various pros and cons.
But even at Stanford,
we have different programs like Ignite,
which is a four-week program, sometimes
actually a seven to nine-week program for
working professionals both on campus and
around the world.
We have a handful of certificates.
There's an innovation and
entrepreneurship certificate online.
There's a LEAD certificate online,
which stands for Learn,
Engage, Accelerate, Disrupt.
We also have an MSX program.
This is a 12 month program, for
those of you with at least
eight years of experience.
So there are so many options out there,
I acknowledge, that will help you grow and
improve.
So it's worth while to pause and
evaluate all of these, and
see which one is really the right fit for
growth and improvement for you.
>> So,
relative to all those other options,
what does an MBA offer would you say?
>> Well, I'm biased of course, but
I'm bullish on the MBA, and that's for
two reasons.
The first is the incredible
versatility of this degree.
As I mentioned, the focus of an MBA
here at Stanford, it's not on a narrow
specific career path, it's not on
a narrowly defined set of skills.
It's actually on broad
applicable concepts.
So, innovative thinking, the personal
leadership development, self awareness,
interpersonal experiences,
understanding and
navigating the global
landscape around you.
These are all very valuable skills
in a very versatile sense, and
so this is a skill set that actually
makes you a very versatile professional.
>> So, the MBA isn't just for
people pursuing careers in business?
>> No, not at all.
These skills are applicable all
across different career paths,
across different cultures.
And frankly, very appropriate for
a world that's changing rapidly around us.
So, the diversity of the skill
set is broad and versatile.
The community is also very broad.
And so, this is a community that provides
perspectives that are much more varied
than you often find in the workplace,
or in other graduate degree programs.
Again, people are coming from
all these different backgrounds.
And that gives you
a learning environment and
the laboratory to expand your
perspective and abilities.
So that's one reason, the second reason
why I'm bullish on the MBA, it's the idea
of the curation of all of these
distinct experiences coming together.
So, sometimes people ask me why
would I even bother with the MBA?
And that's a fair question.
So in my opinion,
I believe it's impossible to curate,
all by yourself, all of the experiences
that an MBA simultaneously offers.
Can you replicate classroom learning
with the faculty that we have here?
Right.
Can you replicate the emphasis on
innovation, the immersive
opportunities to practice leadership,
the global experiences.
Can you curate this all on your own?
Can you assemble 400 plus people who are
some of the most amazing and inspiring and
ambitious future leaders to make
that your own support network?
But if you can do all this on your own,
then maybe you don't need the MBA, but
if you recognize value in immersing
yourself in environmental where all of
this comes together, then I encourage you,
take a good long look at a Stanford MBA.
Now, I should mention one other thing.
Some of you are interested in Management
Education and a Business Degree.
You're also interested in studying
something else simultaneously.
And this is a really exciting and
growing area in business and MBA schools.
It's the idea of doing
a joint dual degree.
And so, many schools,
Stanford among them, offer the opportunity
to study business and something else.
And so, if that applies to you,
you can pursue that.
We'll actually talk more about joint
dual degrees in another one of these
discussions coming in the next few months.
>> Thanks, Luke.
Another question, when is the right
time for me to go back to school?
>> Well, let me address
an important distinction here so
there are different times
to apply to school.
If, let's say you're applying to
Stanford as a college senior, or
as a current graduate student who has
continued straight through from undergrad.
You have the option of applying for
admission, and if you're admitted,
deferring your admission to a future year.
So, similarly,
if you're already working, but
you are interested in applying
to a joint or dual degree,
you may also defer your admission
to pursue that other degree first.
So those of you that fall
into those groups have
some flexibility about when you start.
Now, if you're already working and
you're not applying for a joint or
a dual degree, we do expect you to apply
in the year when you plan to enroll.
So for those of you who are in this
position, this is a very important and
a very timely question to ask.
And the short and simple answer is,
when you're ready.
You go back to school when you're ready.
And, you know, remember our
dispelling of the myth earlier that
you could have too little experience or
too much experience.
That's not true.
This frees you up to apply at that point
in your career when you are truly ready.
>> So the obvious question is,
how would you know if you're ready?
>> Yeah.
Sure.
Well, I believe the right time
is when you are ready for
change, when you're ready for
some sort of change.
Now, that is defined different ways for
each of you.
All right, for some of you, that might
be changing the very work that you do.
You want to change industries.
You want to change the very nature
of the work that you're doing.
Others of you may like the industry you're
in, or the company you work for, but you
want to change your approach, and how you
think about the work that you're doing.
So there are different ways to define
this, but I believe that, the time to know
when you're ready, it's when you recognize
this opportunity to advance your passions.
To advance your interests by making
this investments in yourself, and
the impact you have on your community.
>> Isn't there a cost, though,
to interrupting your career?
>> Yeah, sure, in fact,
I think of two costs.
The first cost is a financial cost.
Right now, business school is not only
an investment in yourself, in your skills,
it's also a literal financial investment,
and
I acknowledge you spend
money to come to school.
But I also hope that you don't
consider that a deterrent.
And so, we're fortunate at Stanford to
have a very generous need-based financial
aid program, and this helps fund students
based on your financial need to attend,
so we strive to eliminate
that as a barrier for study.
Now, the second cost is opportunity
cost of stepping away from your career.
And so, for a full time MBA like Stanford,
that is stepping away for 2 years,
perhaps even longer if you are pursuing
one of the joint dual degree programs.
And so there are professional
considerations, there are personal.
It's considerations.
Are you moving a family,
are you delaying some
other goal that's involve in your personal
life to come and study at business school?
I acknowledge all of these things.
So, when you think about this cause
I want to return to the framework of
business school as an investment,
it's an investment in yourself.
It's an investment in your future, and
it's an investment in the communities, and
the impact that you'll have within them.
So, those of you who have
experience with investing no,
with an investment
there's an up front cost.
And, as with any worthwhile investment,
there are also rewards
that justify that cost.
And so, you know, the rewards here
from an MBA and from a Stanford MBA,
they may be financial, but I actually
believe the more valuable rewards
manifest themselves in the form of
a career impact, a life of meaning.
So I say think not just
about the short term cost,
think about the long-term rewards that
pay dividends for the rest of your life.
And so when you're ready, regardless of
your career stage, when you're ready to
make this investment that does have the
short-term cost, but pays the long-term
dividends in impact and meaning,
that's when you know it's the right time.
Third question,
is this the right school for me?
>> Hm, there's so
many schools around the world, and so
many of them offering
management education.
And sometimes this can feel like a curse,
because there's an abundance of options,
but I actually encourage you
to think of it as a blessing,
because each school is different.
And that means each one has
a different value proposition.
Now, there's a myth that we didn't dispel
earlier, but I want to dispel now.
That myth is that there is some universal
ranked order of schools and that a higher
ranked school is inherently better than
a lower ranked school for all of you.
That's simply not true.
Each one of you listening has a different
set of schools that are best for you,
and this is based on a widely
varying set of personal criteria.
So in this sense do
the research on the schools and
do that research not based on some list or
what somebody else says is right.
Apply your criteria that's important.
So for some of you,
you'll care about location.
Some of you will care about
the culture of the school.
Some of you will care about how
are you taught in the class,
what are the teaching methods?
Some of you care about,
is it a general management program or
other concentrations and majors that
allow you to very deeply specialize?
So pay attention to the criteria, but
pay attention in regards to your
specific set of interests and desires.
>> What would you say
differentiates Stanford?
>> Hm, well, I think of this in
three frames, in three elements, and
they're progressively deeper.
So the first element is
programmatic features.
Okay so,
these are things like location, right?
So we're in California and
this is a place where there's enthusiasm
about innovation and
exploring the unknown.
I think about the structure
of the program.
So ours is a general
management curriculum.
So we focus on broad applicable skills
that are transferable across industries.
All right, we focus on things like
experiential leadership rather than
strictly theoretical instruction.
In fact the classroom instruction.
It's a combination of both research,
faculty and practitioners.
So these are the programmatic elements.
If you go one level deeper,
you look at the people in a community.
So at Stanford we have a small class.
It's just over 400 in each class.
And the students get to know each other
not just as classmates but as friends and
as people that they can count
on to support one another.
All right,
it's a feedback dominated culture.
So we encourage students to practice
giving each other feedback and
to develop each others leadership
through this practice.
Now the alumni community, as a result
of the small, tight knit community,
it's very strong, it's very responsive.
But then you go even one level deeper and
you arrive at the values.
And so the values of a place like Stanford
focus on personal transformation.
They focus on self awareness.
And ultimately focus on
values based decision making.
And making decisions based on what
has meaning and impact for you.
So this, to me, suggests a really powerful
insight about the values at Stanford.
When you come here and
you graduate we hope that your pursuit and
your goal is not success, success is fine.
It's a good thing.
It's fine to want, but we hope that's not
the primary goal because it's superficial.
It's temporary, and
time's completely out of our control.
So if this is your goal,
you may or may not find it.
So instead, we encourage you to position,
to transform and
think of the goal as happiness and
meaning, and purpose.
And so, these are noble pursuits that
you can, in fact, attain and achieve.
So if this is your pursuit,
chances are you'll find it, and
chances are you're more likely
to find success as a byproduct.
>> Sounds all pretty aspirational.
What tactical steps can our listeners
take to determine if Stanford or
another school is right for them?
>> Sure, two suggestions.
The first, engage with us.
We've got lots of
opportunities to engage with
the Stanford community as well as
other business school communities.
So if you're so inclined,
come and see us on campus.
If you can't visit campus,
attend one of the events around
the world that we put on.
Check us out online.
We have more of these
online events coming.
We've got some great videos online,
look at student profiles.
So we put out a lot of content for
you to understand the school.
Now, this is a lot of data and
information from the school but
it can be one directional.
So, you also have to self access.
You have to take action in response
to learning about the school and
self access to make sure the community
is aligned with your own values.
And I think one simple trick for this is
look at what the school is asking you.
For example, in the application essays,
sketch out some light responses and
see what reaction you have.
If you get excited about that,
that tells you one thing.
And if you have a different reaction,
that may tell you another thing
about your fit with the school.
>> Great, Luke, let's move on now
to answering audience questions.
Thanks to so many of you who
submitted questions in advance.
Okay, what are some things we
can do three to six months prior
to submitting an application
to a full time MBA program?
Three to six months,
this is a great time for reflection.
I think sometimes the temptation is to
think of the application as just a series
of check boxes and steps that you
have to go through to be a candidate.
But actually, reflection goes a long way
towards helping you know if this is truly
the right path for you.
So once you've decided that this
is the right path, plan it.
Now set, put together a plan.
Look at the deadline for
when you want to apply and
work backwards from that deadline.
So that you prepare and
give yourself enough time.
I also encourage you to
identify the resources
that will help you best for preparing.
And so resources look like they
manifest in a lot of different ways.
But I think maybe the most important
is get the people around you who
will be your support network, who can
give you feedback on your application and
who can give you guidance on preparing for
this big step.
And then finally as I mentioned,
check in with yourself along the way.
Self assess, how are you feeling?
How are you responding as you're
moving through this process?
Are you excited?
Are you not?
Are you dreading it?
This is valuable feedback for yourself
that you should take into consideration.
>> This next question is
about application rounds.
I've heard that admissions rates differ
between different application rounds.
How should this factor into our decision
about which round to apply for?
>> Well,
you should apply when you are ready, and
when your application is complete.
Now I think its important to know,
we do not enter a round with a quota for
admission offers.
We don't go into a round with
a fixed admission rate in mind.
The number of admission offers in a round
depends on the number of qualified
candidates relative to the pool, and
that changes from one round to the next,
from one year to the next, and
it's not something we predict.
So apply when you're ready.
I do think it's wise to apply as early
as your application is complete.
Round three has historically been
a very competitive round for us.
And in the last few years, we've received
more applications in round two, and
that's made that round more competitive.
So, on the margin, I would say,
apply as early as you can,
but, the most important factor
is that you should feel
your application is complete and
you are ready to submit.
>> Luke, what advice do you have for more
traditional applicants who already have
some exposure to the MBA
application process?
What should they focus
on in their preparation?
>> Well, the focus should be on yourself.
And what do I mean by that?
You want to really,
truly examine why this path,
this MBA, this timing, and
this school is right for you.
And I think this is
a specially critical for
those of you where there are many
candidates applying from your company or
from your industry because there is
a temptation to fall under group think.
Right?
Everybody else is applying to the school
or applying at this time in their
career so yo you should too.
Now, let me challenge that, you want to
resist that temptation, I think you also
have to work to resist the temptation
to try to differentiate yourself.
And again, you see yourself
wanting to position yourself and
compare yourself to the others
that you know who are applying.
I say, let go of that.
It's hard, but let go of that.
Those who try hardest to stand out in this
process are usually the ones who end up
standing out the least.
So instead of trying to be different,
just be yourself.
And that's the best way to be a great
candidate, and let that sense of self and
identity really emerge.
>> Here's a question from an international
student who asks, if I've already visited
the campus and attended a class, what are
some of the other opportunities I should
be looking out for which will help me
understand the Stanford culture better?
>> Hm, I like that idea of culture.
Culture is such a significant part of
the business school experience it's
certainly a differentiating
factor among business schools.
And so this is an important
thing to pay attention to.
Now, culture isn't manufactured
in the abstract by a school.
No, it forms and emerges from the people
who are part of that community.
So to really understand a culture,
you have to understand the people.
What do they value?
What drives them?
What gives them passion and meaning.
And so this actually allows me to lump
in another question that we received.
And that question is, is there a way to
connect with Standford GSB students or
alumni as we prepare to apply?
And this is in the spirit of wanting
to get to know that culture.
Absolutely.
We want you to know our community,
to know our students and alums, and so
we have a lot of ways
that you can do this.
Right, if you do visit campus, we have
students here who speak at our sessions,
especially when school is in session.
And we have class visits, but
even if you've already visited campus, or
you can't visit campus, we're going out in
the next few months all over the world and
hosting events in the large
metropolitan areas of the world.
We feature alumni and
students at those events and so
it is a way to directly engage.
We have a lot of great
information on the web,
there are social media
profiles of students,
we have a week in the life series where
students highlight what a week in their
life looks like, we've got some great
new videos on our YouTube channel.
Where students talk about what
the experience is like at the school.
And so you've got faculty videos,
visiting speaker videos, so
there's some great content online
where you can understand the culture.
There's also these events where you can
interact with students and alums directly.
>> Does admissions see and
care if an applicant has visited campus?
>> We're delighted to
have you visit campus.
We're delighted to offer
you these opportunities.
We have information sessions Monday and
Friday all throughout the year.
We have class visits
during three quarters.
The fall, the winter, and
the spring when classes are in session.
We even have larger visit programs.
These are coming this September.
So things like mini voices for
diverse perspectives.
We have an XX factor event for
women who want to change the world.
We've got a visit day which
is a general visit event,
and these are day long events.
Now, we have these opportunities but
I want to be very clear,
we offer these to help you understand
the Stanford experience and
culture and many applicants find this to
be a helpful step in preparation, but
we do not weigh them in
our evaluation process.
It's very important to preserve
fairness and equity, and
we understand that some of you have the
opportunity to visit, some of you do not,
and so it's not an advantage or
a disadvantage in the evaluation process.
It's for your research.
>> All right, Luke,
we're almost out of time.
If you didn't get your
question answered today,
feel free to contact our office by
email or phone to answer your question.
Luke, before we go, any words of
advice for our listeners today?
>> Yeah, I've been careful not to talk
too much about the application itself.
It is important to us, but
we wanted to focus today first on
how to get ready to apply, and
we will talk about the application in
a future discussion in this series.
Now that being said, our first essay
question is a question that I believe is
worth considering not just when
completing the application but
also when you're deciding why to apply,
when to apply, where to apply.
And that first question is,
what matters most to you and why?
Okay, so we believe that
the purpose of a Stanford MBA
is to position you to change lives,
change organizations, to change the world.
But in order to do that, you have to
first examine how you might change, and
you might grow, and you might evolve.
And in order to do that,
you have to know and understand yourself.
So before you pick a degree, before
you pick the year or round to apply,
before you pick the schools to apply to,
you owe it to yourself to really,
truly examine who you are, examine what
matters to you, and examine what about
your answer drives and motivates you to
take the step in your career in your life.
If you do that work of self-examination up
front, you will get a better applicant,
you'll be a happier student, and
you'll be a more impactful alum.
>> Great advice Lou, thank you.
And thank you all for joining us.
There are three more MBA admissions
insight conference calls coming up,
including, preparing for
your letters of reference and
essays on July 12th,
being a great applicant on August 10th and
considering a joint or
dual degree on August 31st.
You can sign up for these on our website.
An audio recording of each
of these conference calls,
including the one today, will be posted
on our website in the next few weeks.
The current application is
now available on our website
there're three application deadlines
September 21, January 10, and April 5.
As Luke said earlier, there're lots of
ways to learn more about our program and
the admission process.
On our website you'll find
videos of webinars and
a calendar of events offered both
on campus and around the world.
We look forward to meeting you online or
in person.
Goodbye for now.